whether you love it hated or I've never  thought about it chances are some nanny  wants to ban it pit bulls horse  carriages fireplaces chewing tobacco  chickens shark tours big snakes they  were all on someone's hit list in  September 2009 residents may soon be  banned from keeping large reptiles as  pets same for smoking in parks selling  homemade pie at farmers markets and  getting tattoos that's right busybodies  took aim at all those things you're a  disgusting criminal aren't you but  there's only one any of the month for  summer 2009 the Alabama Supreme Court  for banning sex toys more specifically  for upholding a state law that bans the  selling of any device designed or  marketed as useful primarily for the  stimulation of human genital organs  check back next month for more examples  of busybodies minding your own business  [Music]